we got him I think I think I think uh
let me just double check here to attack
into the Matrix he looks like he's
setting up his audio all right well let
me let me let me audience there you go
fellas there it is there he is
I wanted to give you a proper like click
bait Facebook ads yeah entrance so I
just want to say Banks hate this guy
find out eight tips to get permanently
kicked off YouTube it's it's dick
Masterson ladies and gentlemen I found
it this you know what the secret is to
getting kicked off of uh YouTube uh it's
making fun of fat women oh now if I
don't know if that secret was out of the
bag yet
um I don't know Moby Dick ended up doing
me in the last strike the last [__]
false flagging campaign strike that they
got me on was uh the test holiday video
where I questioned her uh anorexia
diagnosis
medical misinformation that I did or
what but I don't know I feel like I
don't know that's a bit of a stretch are
there a lot of fat chicks you think work
at YouTube but I can't imagine that's
true it seems like they'd all be fit
which is actually funny too we just
played the that Dove commercial for Pat
[__] and video games
did you see this it was [__] wild uh
it was this one here that we need fat
[__] in video games wow
it's the uh it looks like Bowser yes I
mean you see we already have fat women
in video games we have Bowser yeah
um so you got uh so you you got off uh
well you didn't get off YouTube you've
been you've been to YouTube you've been
on YouTube debanked yeah
um what's what are we doing here well
I've been trying to get D women uh I'm
trying that my whole life so that women
collectively will just never talk to me
again but I just can't quite get that
one I don't know how
if you're mean to them they like you
more that's the problem that you can't
be mean to them or they like you more
yeah I keep [__] it up the one thing
that I don't want access to women just
never stops
bro so yeah just we gotta we just got
another strike on our YouTube channel
you know we just post like the first 15
minutes of the show up there now but we
got a strike for an old episode again
another one Marshall for cyber bullying
Jeffrey Epstein so you know whatever man
I swear I swear to God we've received a
lot of takedowns I think that's like the
fifth Epstein related video that was
taken down for harassment and bullying
yeah yeah so I talked to kill himself so
you know oh maybe that's what it is
acceptable to yeah bullying that's right
yeah the [__] Force that's how
they're gonna end us like Alex Jones
we're gonna get sued for bullying
Jeffrey Epstein into suicide we're gonna
get sued by JP Morgan Chase for like 70
billion dollars and we're gonna lose and
we're gonna lose dude it's gonna [__]
happen so so they they took your channel
away then they gave it back and they
took it away again like what happened
yeah like do you guys think I mean you
have you have experience with the the
YouTube's paintings do you think that
like Indians look at this stuff and go
yeah that's fine but and then it so it
it unbanned it reinstated my channel
right and then it comes back to like
white women in America and they say oh
that's not fine actually you're gone
like that's how the chain of command
would work right yeah you give it to the
lowly like unclean first but actually
it's funny because merch and I were just
talking to somebody
uh right who may or may not have access
at some point worked at YouTube put it
to you that way right and specifically
may have worked and and this is just a
couple weeks ago specifically may have
worked in in so they have like an
outreach program for like different
streamers and they're sectioned off like
for like the big left-wing political
streamers they have like a person who
handles them and for the right wing
streamers have a person who handles them
for the comedy streamers they have a
person who handles them right so the way
it works is if you're over a certain
threshold of followers it's harder than
a mass flag right because like if you're
under a certain amount of followers if
they Mass flag you YouTube automatically
hits you with a strike they don't even
think about it but certain channels and
the guy use crowd as an example right
Crowder has protections on his account
where it goes to then it does go to like
you said a fat white woman honestly no
literally that's what it is who one who
looks at it and goes yes or no it's
acceptable not acceptable and then I
asked the dude okay so there's all these
comedy channels all these conservative
channels how many people what team
handles it he goes no it's one person
there's one person when you see that
it's automated and then if it goes high
enough or if you have enough subscribers
or you'll be a problem then it goes to a
real person so you could be banned and
then unbanned like what happened to us
it's a perfect example they demonetized
us and two years ago three years ago now
in July so what we did was we made a
clip Channel completely safe like we
bleeped all the words out it was totally
clean they demonetized that channel
because they said it was associated with
a channel
that yeah so you can't even you can't
even get around it so yes that there is
a chain of command and yes it is a fat
woman that's doing it also they took the
same system that the banks used because
I'm sure that's why I have no credit
card processing is uh because of a
collective of uh of fat women in
different organizations in the banking
system like Specter but like you know
you never want to look at them uh who
got to make the decision on my account
at like Chase Wells Fargo MasterCard
another great system we have here it's
it's still unbelievable to me because I
watch Dick's show I'm very you know we
all I'm not going to say it I'm not
going to say it that way we all love
dick Masterson there you go say it in
full I get cut out the master part no
problem I'm cutting it out so I said it
really fast uh no but it's like there's
I don't other than you just kind of
being a dick there's I don't ever see
anything where it's like oh yeah this
guy really needs to we really yeah you
were thinking about calling from
Revolution we gotta curb this [__]
movement before it overtakes well it is
it is a movement because they're all fat
[__] but yeah it's a counter movement
yeah it's true it's like all the
channels get Banning on Alex Jones you
know Sandy Hook is like what did get
banned for I don't know he called some
fat [__] fat and that's it like that's
the reason
it was that good the joke was so good
it's all about Batman oh man he would
really nail him they had to get rid of
that guy it literally broke the law in
Canada that's how good the joke was it
literally broke the law so I do want to
make sure we plug because you do have
you've been working on this like a
[__] psychopath for a couple years
now but you now have backed dot by right
it's the website yeah thanks for
plugging that I want to get that out
it's patreon on the blockchain
um we tried to take all the blockchain
[__] out of it so you show up you sign
up with your email you can use your
credit card but all the the like
workings of it are all on the blockchain
best thing about the blockchain man is
you cannot get booted off of it like you
I mean unless you're literally North
Korea the U.S government comes in and
says like this is required like they
they have to take you to court they have
to take an entire country to court and
go through it but some fat women can't
just turn you off like whatever you
whatever you put on the blockchain you
use back by
you can't get turned off even if the
government has a gun to my head I can't
turn you off
um I hope people use it I want you guys
to use we'll use it no we're in God use
it we're in good we're in no I mean
there's no reason there's literally
nothing stopping us from using it we can
use it if we want yeah and I I was I I
will say this I plugged it last night on
um on night wave and somebody in the
audience did say that uh somebody said
something to the effect of oh Dick's
using Matic so he's not an idiot or
something to that effect yeah it's a
polygon okay that's Matic that's the
that's the currency they use yeah but
somebody just was saying good things
about it last night as far as it uh
being one of the steadier ones as far as
like not stat you know what I mean it's
but like as far as it not gonna just
disappear tomorrow you know yeah it's a
good point there's some terrifying coins
out there where you're like okay but
what does this do and who wants it it's
like and how many of them are there and
it's like ah don't worry about all that
I'm gonna go to the Moon you're
investing in fact coin it's [__] the
big one coming out next [__] hop on
board dick when will you be accepting
Pepe
okay we're Rumble now let me tell you
something dick I know we had a foot I
know we had a flare-up with Rumble but
great guys yeah they're nice guys great
guys look I'm so hard on Rumble because
I want it to work Amen brother [__]
amen we agree with you screaming what
we've done behind the scenes and in
front of the scenes now but yeah we're
like [__] we want to use it make it
look on the upside at least it took away
having to put the Waiting video now you
don't need to do that [__] anymore thank
God yes good okay number two you need to
make links launch the app it's called
Universe yes send me the programmer
ideal I've dealt with programmers for 20
[__] years I know how they Gaslight
and manipulate people into thinking
something's really hard when it's
[__] not they're just like plumbing
contractors okay find me put me on the
phone with them once a week and I will
fix your [__] products do you speak
Hindu because I don't know how we're
gonna [__] make it happen yeah this
is that right now when I was speaking
that's called Hindu screaming at them
until they start typing don't think just
Buddy Guy Buddy Guy Buddy Guy would do a
Buddy Guy okay can we predict to the
rumble headquarters because I think
within an hour the CEO will be like I
kind of miss drunk Mercy I like it on
Twitter like at least that was just on
Twitter and it was just a couple listen
here you [__]
I want to know what look there trust me
ma'am we want her to work more than
anybody we said that when we had the
meeting we'll be honestly remember we're
like look can you just like copy YouTube
and just give us that but like let it
say stuff that's all we want right
that's all we want just copy YouTube we
just want to do do you remember steal it
if you want steal YouTube's code rip it
off man anything cute I don't give a
[__] all we want to say is the F slur
I'm not even that hype on the n-word to
be honest no me neither be me you know
what you know why it gets overused yeah
I used it in traffic mostly yeah it's a
place for you no because it gets
overused then it becomes an edgy boy
word and honestly when we use it it's
it's it's so rare that it actually has
meaning again you know like it's it you
have to have like have meaning to use it
like you know the good joke where it's
worth it but now when using all the time
well I will never I don't know what I'll
take away from me
I still say that five times a day like
yeah in the mirror yes
that's how I wake up in the morning
skid row and Amazon train robberies so
we have the opportunities to use the
n-word all the time in LA I don't know
if you guys know that it's not like like
a lot of people say like oh yeah I just
use it because of hip-hop now we're
using it the old school Southern racist
way here you guys are the Wild West
again over there for you if you train
robbery so hilarious yeah it's 23-3 and
we have [__] train Heights going on
whatever the hell are you still doing
there
people can go [__] himself with that oh
anybody could move at any time like man
I got a lot of [__] people here and
[__] that I gotta move okay go [__]
yourself Chicken Man Tim pool
he also says it but it's like he's also
saying it to just like poor people you
know what I mean that's just [__]
[__] what do you want what you don't
have uh you don't have like 10K stashed
away
make a YouTube video get a million
dollars and buy a house like I do what's
the [__] problem what happened get it
get a new car get a bigger car that you
can put more of your stuff in if you
need it I think there's that's the one
person that I think dick and I Bond the
most over and hating is Tim Poole on
Twitter he is the most
sufferable person everything he says
like his whole like [__] College
swimmers need to drop their scholarships
because there's trans people I'm like
Bro [__] off these kids are poor and
they need the money to [__] code and
you're like hey all these evil
corporations you're giving them money
you're giving 40 of your money into
YouTube you like why don't you leave
you'll never leave there he's legit like
the only person I know in this like
sector that I would want to call her
you know I don't know why out of all of
them I would just want to grab them by
his collar and have them again you're
jealous of his music yeah not not hurt
him right not hurt him or anything just
pin him down for a second and be like I
could if I wanted to yeah
he's the worst fence riding loser like
everything he posted and the promise
whenever he gets caught he doesn't think
oh maybe I was just trying to be edgy
you're not edgy you're not funny you're
not insightful you're a [__] twerp oh
God I [__] dry drunk but for liberals
like I can tell like you know a dry like
they don't deal with their emotional
issues they just stop drinking like
people's like he's still a liberal yeah
he's still very liberal he's just like
not actively being a huge piece of [__]
anymore but he's still inside he's not
just he's just not voting blue anymore
he's still a huge piece of [__] inside
well that's as long as you're not
drinking that Budweiser beer you [__]
you don't drink that God damn it I put
him I put him in the category of a
Crowder though even if you dismissed all
of his politics or any of his fence
sitting I he's he just exhibits so many
little traits and ticks that over time
you're like this guy's a complete
psychopath you know what I mean like
there's just you know people like that
you can spot them and if they're out
there trust me if they're terminally
online like this over time you can go
this guy's got [__] he's got some
[__] issues man you know Eliza blue I
think [__] everyone in that goddamn
compound is what happened in my opinion
I don't know of any inside knowledge but
I think she [__] everyone in that
compound and they all covered for her
and he's now now he's he's I don't like
[__] drama you [__] live for drama
you love it we all love the drama other
people's drama I get it Tim you don't
like your drama who does God that's so
funny she could [__] too she had that
big fat ass oh yeah yeah but they got
they got her you know a little bit you
know she had she already had like that
she was like a car with like three prior
owners it wasn't like you know I liked
it they're all black guys yeah like I
would have went with pre-wrap video
probably uh version of her the Eno emo
scene girl yeah the emo scene girl man I
still love those emo scene girls back
then but then she turned into this weird
like World Star Hip Hop like mud shark
and I'm like what the [__] is this when
she was banging Gerard Way From My
Chemical Romance that's when she could
have got it instead of little yachty or
whatever
yeah [__] pop smoke
I'm being sex trafficked no you're not
you're a [__] and it's fine I like
[__] if you're admit you're a [__]
oh God did you guys talk about that
Trump rape I mean obviously that Trump
rape conviction whatever it is
so if it like it felt like this genuine
ugly all men felt like I didn't even I
don't even know this woman dude that let
me tell you that was Trump being a
hundred percent genuine and the other
thing that men feel is like I would
never [__] that ugly [__] I'm Donald
Trump and usually the last thing you
want to do when you lose a defamation
suit is go out and go this [__] is
lying I'm never gonna stop I'll pay the
five mil I have it but [__] her dude I
never [__] touched her her stories
were hilarious and she was like it was
very romantic those new stories from
that [__] and she was like yeah you
know you know it depends what do you
consider rape and Anderson Cooper's just
like look we need a [__] keep pushing
this [__] it's so funny you gotta take
this [__] out but it was he he didn't
even care about the rape stuff he
honestly just cared that he would ever
[__] somebody that ugly and you're like
yeah I get it man I get it I [__] get
it yeah she's trying to [__] him you
know you're talking to you he's very
titillating but you're on [__] live
viewer TV what are you [__] doing
and Anderson Cooper's gay calm down
he's not gonna [__] you
dude it's [__] it's it is it is
[__] the dude the Twitter file stuff
speaking another hoe I wouldn't even
talk about it but the the new stuff that
just dropped today where Brittany Lorenz
that shit's [__] wild Taylor Sorry
Taylor and sorry Taylor and sorry yeah
so apparently
um I actually have it here they they um
yeah she's even older than 51. well no
better files guess what she's 53 guys
and I'll be like I don't buy a
screenshot of her phone and the Twitter
files and her fonts are about this big
[__] Jitterbug
um [__] so you get the Jitterbug and
rose gold
Sparkle case on it no so here's what
happened Twitter provided privilege
access to Banning Queen Taylor Lorenz so
uh shortly after Elon Musk bought
Twitter Taylor Owens got uh got upset uh
writing that Twitter was opening the
gates of hell and letting band accounts
back on look it's a couple of them on
the show right now merchanting it feels
so good yeah the ma the month prior
Taylor Owens got this tiny account band
uh this account detailed Taylor Lorenz
is a Manhattan rich girl who attended
Swiss boarding school and whose Uncle
owns the her you know her uncle owns the
internet archive this is something that
hasn't come out yes her uncle owns the
internet archive right and so they the
reason it was so hard to find her real
age and you always thought we always
thought like man it seems kind of weird
how hard it is to find her [__] right
yeah yeah that's why apparently her
uncle was scrubbing everything about her
because she this little account by the
way Neville the cat this account never
broke any terms of service all this was
Public Access and she said Taylor Owens
was born to Mega Rich developer Walter R
Lorenz 65 and Anne Lorenz 67 and raised
in a 5.7 million dollar mansion her
sister is Brooke Lorenz of CNN
so yeah so apparently
um this dude didn't violate the Twitter
rules but she was just sending emails
because she had inside like a fat [__]
at Twitter that was just destroying
accounts for her and just sent and
sending stuff uh sending stuff over and
like just spiking anything that's why
you would think man it's 2023 it should
be easy to figure out her age it took a
while because the internet archive guy
her uncle was just deleting everything
about her for her and they provide a
privileged access Banning uh Banning
Queen uh Twitter Lorenzo yeah it was
basically she was working with him the
entire time that's why the small
accounts you know what that also meant
that this [__] was out there and had a
Google alert for her name and every time
a small account like tweeted about her
she was finding it and just going after
them and taking them out and this is the
same [__] who [__] docks three
people yeah yeah I mean wow yeah it's
just Invincible these people are just
walking around we need a [__]
straight up super villain president next
I really do I'm like I got a foot off
the Trump train I was never on the
DeSantis train but now I'm full on like
whoever is just the worst of the worst
to punish these [__] [__] Elon
a check let's give him that stupid
trillion dollar platinum coin yeah the
treasury Department always makes those
cute headline jokes about give it to him
let him run rampant burn big Tech to the
ground throw our political enemies in
prison for life [__] these people I
don't let's start meeting in beer
gardens I heard that worked out well for
the last guys
start to get together and let's [__]
round them up let's go start rounding
don't do that we're gonna run but we can
but I wouldn't let's start rounding up a
bunch of like-minded men and get arms
you know we round them up okay bro they
give Elon Musk so much [__] for saying
Soros was like Magneto like oh that's
anti-semitic I'm like you always let the
cat out of the bag bro no one said it
was because he was a Jew but apparently
you think it's that it does make me
laugh the Jewish people always like
incriminate themselves and panic and
it's like and it's always and then they
start screaming at you and you're like I
didn't even say anything why are you
yelling at me I made a joke to a friend
and it's like oh so you think okay I see
how it is relax dude I don't think you
killed anybody relax it would be like
white people's [__] drives me insane
that you that comedy Jewish people are
like oh man us white guys are oh hey us
wife real pain in the Keystone huh guys
uh fellow white guys like man thank you
we don't know what you're doing what
you're doing too you're talking to other
white people doing that you [__] dick
stop doing whites ask for it do they
have a phrase ask for it and Yiddish
because that's what you're doing
you're asking for it mister stop with
your white face Ari we know what you're
doing get out of here
uh you invited me to your kids Bar
Mitzvah don't [__] sit here now us
white people we really need to learn a
lesson you know we've been in charge for
too long I will agree you've been in
charge too long but it's not the white
people and they never mess with it they
never slip up that's how good the Jews
they're good oh you know when they when
they put all the white people in the
holoca I mean uh like they never they
never do that they always keep them
separate somehow they're so goddamn good
at it they're [__] the best don't you
wish that other people like other people
could actually like rally together like
that and not slip up but they man they
really just they keep it tight like they
keep their little battles inside and
like we're [__] like hey you know
what we know what we're doing but we're
gonna fool and you're right and then to
me whenever they whenever something bad
happens it's like white guy does this
but whenever it's an achievement it's
like first Jewish person to do this I'm
like all right man that's right folks
we're on the Free Speech platform and
he's on the blockchain and we're calling
out here that's what's happening we're
pivoting back we're going we're going to
an alt-right show Patriot front it's
gonna be bigger the like I've been
talking about the blockchain for years I
hope people start listening the jump
from like old web to this user-generated
content like web 2 uh was huge I mean
that's where all these creators came
from but unfortunately all these big
companies like Google made all of our
money right by housing our data and
owning our data and just selling access
to it the jump to web 3 of creators
actually owning their data and Their
audience like their entire online
identity without having to deal with any
giant conglomeration is going to be uh
huge over the next 10 20 years like um
it's a it's a big white bill I always
try to keep that in mind because I
[__] hate waking up every day worried
if I'm gonna have my worried if I'm
gonna get the email from patreon saying
well you know yeah that was one too many
fat jokes I'm afraid you're you now have
to go down and live in skid row and we
told them what you said about them and
the problem with the patreon stuff is
he's a you know we were on there and
it's it's it even says in their things
like they could kick you off or even
stuff you do not on patreon yeah and and
there's no strikes or anything no it's
just like you're done you're out get out
and you're done and then then you lose
access to like dude I mean you then you
lose access to all your fans so all the
emails all that like you can't even like
back them up and then you're [__] I I
agree dick made a difference his own
patreon and a bunch of people came over
there and the bank went no no sorry no
no
um sorry uh and that's that's part of
the like the the banks too the payment
processors they still own your
connection to your audience with backed
by you own it like on your wallet or
email and nothing can nothing can sever
that tie between you and your fans which
is great because that's what always
happens like you know you you know
there's of course you're always going to
have a large fan base that's going to
follow you but for the most part
especially on YouTube you find out a big
percentage of your fans are casual fans
that come across you and they'll go on
YouTube or this and that it's you know
there's of course the die hards that
watch everything and that's what happens
when they kick you off of YouTube you
you lose that casual interaction like
the people that walk in and bump those
numbers up and stuff like that because
they they cut you off yeah even when you
get a strike you're losing all the walk
by business exactly
and and then that completely disconnect
you no there's no way to do finding a
way to do this to not have pissed off
one wrong person and have all your [__]
getting taken down now it's getting like
really bad I mean anything that [__]
cuts out any middleman I think is 100 a
good idea until they figure out a [__]
that I mean you know I don't know how
they would but who knows right
I don't know they're trying they're um
VC companies are trying to buy their way
in and like shut it down but uh I don't
think they're going to be able to do it
there's too many of them then BlackRock
is going to come and offer Dick like
[__] 30 million dollars you need to
sell everything to them
and he's probably in a heartbeat maybe
Billy I can't get a billion but there's
a number there is a number though it's a
billion and they'll be like look we have
this island that no one's using anymore
so I'm just saying if you want a little
vacation in the Bahamas we got a place
I'll do Russell Brand style like guy on
the inside yeah guys I'm here in the
[__] pedophile room I had to do a
bunch of weird stuff to get in here but
I wanted to give you the inside look
yeah Russell Brand is like the [__]
cop in South Park that was dressed like
a prostitute in [__] the Johns and
then being like can you believe it
that's what he's just another one
Russell Brands were people he's look I
don't know he fool he fools these people
right into like oh mate I'm just like
you mate you're a [__] you [__]
Kristen Bell shut the [__] up oh you
talking about Russell Brand yeah no my
favorite thing about Russell Brand on
this thing is like oh today we're going
to be speaking about you know the Kelvin
vaccine lockdowns and and then it's like
you find out oh I am also dating a
wolf's child which he's literally
no one talks about that that's amazing
well we talk about it we talk about it I
joked about it in the rumble Studio
remember I was like oh I'm banging a
Rothschild I didn't just like change the
name or like divorce her but make it
hard to find the connection you know
it's not they don't even know dude
that's what I was telling Merce like
when we were younger like in like the
early 2000s and 90s there was always
psyops but like they were at least they
tried hard like they put in the work
where you're like man they really got us
fooled now they're like yeah we're lying
dude what are you gonna do [__] off bro
but it sucks because in the old days
remember like Old Pro Wrestling they
kept K Fabe alive the bad guys good guys
had their own locker rooms they drove it
separately and it's like wrestling
compared to then to now now like the
elites are the same way it's like we
don't even pretend to be like anime
like the two guys that were beating the
[__] out of each other are just at the
bar later having a steak and they're
like now they have podcasts yeah right
yeah their actual thoughts are like are
like slights like passive aggressive
slices they're all tweets yeah but
that's the real wrestling now it's so
good it's so good you guys are just us
on steroids yeah basically [__]
yourselves it's dude it's so funny too
because we actually played a few months
ago Hannity had on a noob you said you
reminded me of this new podcast which
was get this the [__] the dude from
um uh the guy the the the the the the
where's the Beret that's always in the
subway oh yeah the guardian angel
Guardian Angels guys doing a podcast
with Anthony Weiner on my life
yeah and Hannity's on there because he's
friends with the hills Angels guys
they're just talking you could tell it's
like why is this happening you mean the
dude who said this dick to a 15 year old
through the show with a [__]
vigilance it's
you're right and you're right they all
do podcasts and they all get pushed and
and and I don't know man it's like
you're always afraid of like curtising
yeah it's gonna and it's it's like you
always worry it's like okay everyone
says they're free speech until someone
gets pissed you know until someone gets
mad or into a record until they get a
[__] sponsor and then you're like
then what you know it sucks because like
it feels like you become like a nomad
you know you're talking about Rumble
well yeah Rumble two everywhere like
every every site we said it about Rumble
two it's like anything could be anything
that could be compromised right anything
could be if you get a big enough not
saying that's happening I'm just saying
if there is a big enough person it is
because they're on the NASDAQ like the
NASDAQ can at any moment say well yeah
in order to be on the attack you have to
comply to this and they legally can't
say no because it would be devastating
to the share prices or there's so many
institutional problems with the banking
system that you cannot get rid of
without leaving I'm so sick of all these
white people running the banks am I
right dick or forget about NASDAQ hear
me out on this and this is crazy I've
never heard of this happening before
what if like uh I just think of this out
of the what if like MasterCard said for
instance like Hey We're Not Gonna Let
You
process MasterCard anymore unless you
get rid of the show then what do you do
I've never heard of that happening I'm
just saying theoretically what happened
that would be if I was the guy that
happened to I'd be [__] pissed
but you're right the system is [__]
rigged if you have any if you're right
now you're building a shareholders so if
they go [__] you no you you have to well
you know look the one I will say the
good thing that I think Elon did do was
take the company private I think that
was a smart thing that he did keep the
not saying that it's I still think that
there's a [__] FBI agent that works
at Twitter don't get me wrong oh yeah
there's no way there's not they won't
allow that guy to exist if not but at
least there's a little less pressure
that can be put on it you know but I
mean at the end of the day elon's
another one it's free speech except for
[__] Alex Jones or because a baby
died once or some [__] yeah it's really
annoying that Alex Jones is like the
stand-in for Satan it is Hitler's losing
his charm you know he's like well you
know people people just see Hitler he's
black and white we need like a big fat
sweaty guy yeah we we need somebody that
said horrendous things that we didn't
care about until he like Trump then all
of a sudden they cared the moment we
stopped like embracing him as our crazy
old drunk uncle like America started
falling apart that's exactly what Alex
Jones was like a real part of this
family Fabric and we needed him yeah he
kept us he kept us all in check but uh
hey where is um where are you gonna be
now because obviously you know yeah it's
a good question with YouTube
um where are they going to be able to
well Rumble I guess I'm gonna I really
wish they would fix yeah I really wish
I'm only asking because we have like 3
300 people watching and I want to make
sure we plug the [__] Rumble
patreon.com the dick show I'll I'll post
it there I I yeah it'll be rumble or I
don't know should I get a cozy Channel
hey man dude my advice be on as many
things as you can at the same time for
now that's that's honestly get you know
I'm sure you have a restream account
just fun get restreaming
aren't there like there's a couple
people on cozy that have nothing to do
with like all them you know all them
[__] slinging right like they're just on
there I like I like cozy I like Nick uh
I'll be on Rumble
um you're talking about casual fans you
know uh talking about casual fans the
first time I streamed on Rumble I walked
to the studio and asked my girlfriend
hey how'd the show go and she goes uh I
couldn't get the app to work so I didn't
watch yeah man I know I know you can
only work on the computer I'm like so
you couldn't watch it in the [__]
computer
well they okay go outside to be fair
they did update the app for the Droid
and for the iPhone and it's working now
I can tell you that because I updated it
so again we call them out but they have
fixed that so the app is working what
they they and they actually have the app
now on the Apple TV on Roku and they're
getting an app that's coming out for the
Xbox and the PlayStation too for people
to watch it on the TV and [__] so
hopefully that stuff goes up but the
main issue that we're taking they need
to fix for Android is is that you you
still can't donate through the Android
app you could it makes me like
borderline suicide right because now
you're cutting off a good amount of you
know money that could be coming in
during every episode and it's like yeah
people go donate the ways but you look
man you're asking people to give you
five dollars for an internet show or
whatever you don't want to jump through
hoops you know you don't want them to
think about it yeah exactly just go go
go go press a button yeah yeah good done
pull the slot machine yes thank God it's
basically just three card Monty you know
this Sunday I'll do an open show so
everybody could see it it's three card
Monty but all three cards are losers
yeah
right right here
one two three oh [__] oh God you're
right we know we're [__] you know what
we're the jokes now that you we're the
[__] jokes we're trying so hard and
they're like oh you all have to do is be
like yeah you don't get to exist anymore
all right they really are so like I
spend way too much time [__] just
looking for a place to stream because I
want to make fun of fat women
it's really a lot of work
just wanted to go on YouTube and say
like oh wow look at this [__] [__]
100 and it's best but it's it's so funny
because you people think it's just a
polyp but it's not just a Pog any funny
stuff you can't even tell [__] jokes
anymore yeah it's like I just won't be
funny and get paid for it and just you
know chill with my friends and then it's
like no I have to carry a fire
extinguisher around everywhere I know
there's just always a new fire breaking
out in the hall and every morning I wake
up every morning I'm waking up hoping
when I look at my phone I don't see
Community guideline [__] thing from
YouTube bro he's so flinchy
dog dude I'm a beat dog dude everything
I look at YouTube like oh no okay that's
just a Creator update yeah oh [__] I
thought it was one of the strikes yeah
hey here's your creator uh insights for
the month and you see an email from
YouTube you're like what now and what
did I oh okay and then and then the
worst part is then they give you a
strike oh my God it's just a bunch of
black clip art yes
a bunch of generic workplace [__]
yeah clip art of people
with headsets I forgot it was Black
History Month oh oh god oh today's
Nelson Mandela's birthday okay God I
thought I thought I was [__] oh it's
just it's a picture of a black guy with
dreads and like shiny jeans and he's
holding a boom box and like all the LGBT
colors are pouring out of the speakers I
love it there you go that's all yours
YouTube give
gave you your
your creator rewind this year my boy out
in memoriam at that Creator like a
Creator we won't rewind and then like a
hate speech that would have been great
everybody like you know with the sad
music like at the Oscars be honest right
remember you would you have been more or
less angry at YouTube if they'd actually
like when they kicked like Nick Fuentes
and all those guys off a few years ago
like Alex Jones if they really did just
do an immemorium during the Creator
rewind I'd be like yeah because you know
what if you're gonna take the shot at
least be fun it's a black and white
picture of dick and underneath it says
his State start date and end date it
goes making fun of Tess holiday it's
this reason for being bad dude that was
the last straw right
I don't think that was a quote-unquote
mass flag if that video did well enough
I guarant [__] it to you that was a PR
Company
not a Puerto Rican Puerto Rican company
unless it's a car wash there's nothing
to do with power washing okay I know
what I'm saying
I'm saying that yeah it might have been
like because that's the other way they
go about it is they'll get somebody's
got enough juice juice
um and Juice Stop talking about
um they can just call YouTube and be
like yo you know we do a lot of [__]
with you guys and oh yeah that's the
other thing with the YouTube guy told us
is that if the video is older than like
three months that's Mass flagging
because the algorithm doesn't it doesn't
go back that far what scans a video Once
basically so unless it's being flagged
so if it's an older video near being
flag if it's a new video it's probably
the algorithm catching it and you know
but it could have legit just gotten back
to her and she could have been like I
hate this call YouTube and she could
have cried maybe you made her cry maybe
it was worth losing she's in her she's
anorexic dick have some love She's
anorexic she's wasting away
well maybe I triggered her into eating
something to cure yeah I wish it was a
[__] shotgun
um
it wouldn't work it wouldn't work you'd
need something like a rhino
guns
something that can Pierce a light
armored vehicle
oh for what's Ahab doing can we [__]
can we get him maybe he can [__] help
us out no and then I may have you are
you're actually really are brought down
by my
you're hunting 37 mopey Dixon
you're a Japanese fisherman dick you're
not Ahab I'm so I'm surprised I'm
surprised the water displacement isn't
drowning him
I'm gonna change my [__] to the
nishimaru
I I like it the whole thing in Canada hi
yes
and then the best part is to give you a
strike right and they don't tell you
what it is so you like a two-hour
episode you're like look I bullied like
three people I don't remember which one
it was how do I know they gave me one
and I was like what I mean there was it
was it I listed all the people are like
well actually it was uh it was it was
hate speech um and I think it was
there's no way to tell but I think it
was I said that Kanye was in a fight
with O.J Simpson who changed his
pronouns to they them uh says Kanye says
they run the banking institution okay OJ
the juice you know he says the juice
runs the banking institution the juice
gets away with murder the Jews cost all
the wars in the worlds and the Jews O.J
Simpson the juice is like actually it's
all it's all black people's fault
jocking for trying to see who's the most
they said that was hate speech that's
probably that's incredible satire off
the top of my head they don't have
satire internet culture they have no
satire they don't understand context
dude it's a bunch of fat women who've
been gassed up into thinking they're
special and they're powerful the worst
thing we ever did was give fat hoes
confidence I was saying this before and
here's why I've been watching and check
it out again called scam fish right and
it's basically this company what's
brilliant rather they they help they
help people that are getting catfished
and these fat hoes that think they're in
that think they're in love with like
this [__] thought that she was in love
this fat [__] that the the guy an actor
in stranger things was in love with her
she was getting catfished she left her
husband and her child oh my God it's
because these hoes are getting gassed up
by Dove commercials and by [__] lizzo
and I said it earlier if [__] [__]
love lizzo so much why do they get mad
when you say they look like them see
then you don't love her that much it
really is a mind [__] huh no because
they're getting gassed up and they know
it and we
actually Forrest mommy said it too when
she was on the show it's like the
problem is is there's not enough hot
people there's too many not hot people
that think that they have power and that
is what's doing it because this is their
Revenge dude this is their revenge for
bullying them
yeah
um they we should sue them yeah
[__] it's gonna be a big lawsuit uh
the settlement's gonna be have to be
held at a Golden Corral yeah can we just
can we like can we like actually you
know price this uh lawsuit by the pounds
oh my if we do it by the pound we're
gonna make some Doughboys I think we
could really do this if we just [__]
weigh these [__] out I know a lawyer
who could help us he's the worst lawyer
in the world uh he's the one that so you
remember when I got sued by Maddox for
like half a billion dollars oh of course
yeah so the lawyer who represented him
who's a total scumbag uh he is now uh
try he's now trying to sue me for a
possession of Kevin a landau.com his
domain name
wait what okay so somebody somebody
bought his name okay.com and they wrote
just about what a shitty lawyer he is
okay because he because that's the guy
that cost me like 50 of course put
another guy and cost another guy like
his whole life and job so they just
wrote about a shitty lawyer he was and
it happens to rank first for his name so
he got the lawyer got all been out of
shape and filed this like arbitration
claim with internet to get the domain
back he sent a it's like a 160 page pure
Spaghetti Factory lawsuit to them about
how it's like earned his first personal
and professional reputation again he has
all these screenshots from my Reddit of
people making oh my god oh no it's so
[__] funny we read the whole thing
last night in the previous episode it's
like
that's [__] brilliant oh that's
[__] hilarious and he just
automatically was like you're doing this
we have too many lawyers we have too
many lawyers there's too many lawyers
that's the problem we've had far too
many lawyers for a long time now uh
stasher five dollars says of course Jews
are great at keeping up white face all
the other ones that weren't died in
something in the 30s and four okay come
on man don't do you can't that's you
know if there was any Jewish people that
worked at Rumble they'd be very upset
Forest mommy ten dollars to keep making
fun of fat and ugly people thank you
thank you for the 10 bucks thanks Chuck
Norris Gun Club two dollars no uggles
gang gang friends yes that's right amen
and do I have one more here let me check
here Android is for Boomers and
Communists look bro that's like 50 of
the phones uh RC propaganda when five
dollars when your end when your NWO your
NWO for life well not necessarily uh
yeah man I mean it's these two are lwo
we're very white Hispanic people I'll
have you know sir so this is you know by
Vince McMahon standard nobody hates
[__] more than me but but yeah right
now nobody hits [__] more than me all
right I couldn't work uh two days in a
row if my life depended on it what is
that [__] that's [__] that sounds
insane that's the most real thing said
by the way
are you [__] kidding me yard work
suck my dick tomorrow no next weekend
maybe yeah getting up at 4 a.m that's
when I go to bed [__] I'm not getting
up at four all right I've only [__]
lawn people do that why don't we do this
at night when it's cold guys come on
come on [__] hot as [__] right here
mowing people's Lawns at three in the
morning good morning neighbor
Jesus [__] Christ oh [__] man I just
see you dropped another appeal now hey
guys hey YouTube we love you guys you're
nice people and uh you know yeah it'll
be nice until they tell them no yeah
there you go see there you go they
responded oh okay oh [__] those
Jews you could say it here it's Rumble
say whatever you want until they tell us
we can't uh and then we'll leave uh this
is it so dick let's plug your [__] one
more time because we gotta hit out of
here now
um
the dick show yeah go to back dot by
register it's just like patreon but uh
you can never be terminated we're gonna
make an account where I mean yeah I'm
gonna make what I mean how much I'm
gonna pour into it right away but I want
to make one and start putting it on the
support thank you thank you yeah for
sure and then I'll be here on uh Sunday
I'll do my show and post my stuff here
they won't let me put the dick show into
title because of the swear filter oh
they should they should now I texted him
about that you should know oh yeah okay
I'll try it again yeah give it a shot it
used to be one word squeezed together I
don't know I'll put it on my Twitter
I'll pick Masterson on Twitter thanks
guys no dude anytime bro if we ever make
it out to your to that hell hole of
California we will absolutely do
something not likely but sure but if we
do we should do another live show
together so that was that was so much
[__] fun dude let's plan another one
we're always down the best time yeah and
it's not covered now we're more people
out yeah cool see you guys all right man
take it easy dude take care
well 5 30 and I'm like all right no
problem and then we kept talking well
because he thought it was sick he
thought it was 6 30 so he actually did
have the time oh cool that worked out
that was great man
it's always easy when he wouldn't throw
out the dick I mean the funny thing is
so we were supposed to have top lops on
I literally asked dick last night like
late at night during night wave I'm like
hey you want to come on Tuesday and he
was like yeah sure I was like you talk
about the you know the backed up eye and
the YouTube [__] and he was like yeah
yeah sure man and then uh uh you hit me
up today and you were like hey you want
to make because we have another guest
Monday Monday because we're going to
move our guests to Tuesday because I
didn't tell him we had dick for two so I
said fine top Lobster addicted let me
see if dick would come worked out great
though and the both people were gonna
have on are people that are getting
banned on one platform or the other it's
getting bad man it really it really is I
want to give him a shout out yeah I mean
first a good guess stick Master since
the [__] best